all right as far up as you can go a
quick dip of a net and proof of a
healthy ecosystem baby bluegill
numbering in the thousands called this
pretty Pond home but they better watch
out for the bass and crappie that share
this water a one acre Pond can really
produce a lot of fish Grundy County
director Craig Kimbro is one of three UT
extension agents Statewide who serve as
Pond Consultants Craig covers Middle
Tennessee helping farmers and land
owners build improve or maintain ponds
there's a lot more to ponds than just
digging a hole and letting it fill
sometimes they like to have the pond but
they don't really manage it well and
it's not really because they do it on
purpose it's just because they forget to
manage one common mistake is having a
pond that's too deep this 1 acre Pond is
about 6 feet in the middle which is just
about ideal also you'd think crystal
clear water would be the goal but water
that too clear allows too much sunlight
in which leads to weed growth you want
some algae growth in there some
phytoplankton growth in there so that
the sunlight can't penetrate that pond
floor Craig says semi murky works best
if you can see past 18 Ines under the
water through the water column then it's
probably too clear and it really needs
to be treated with some kind of pond dye
or maybe try to fertilize it there are
more than 200,000 small lakes and ponds
in Tennessee many of them privately
owned about a quarter of all the fishing
in our state happens on small bodies of
water like this one at two dozen Acres
you might label this a small Lake again
though it's not very deep landowner J
Argo loves to invite friends and family
over to fish I think we put in
approximately 5,000 Blu Gill uh
2,000 um hybrid crappie a good thousand
bass too but this is also a genuine
working Pond providing irrigation for a
vegetable farm and Nursery ponds are a
great help to agriculture it's such a
such a beneficial resource to this area
for sure to our state uh to be able to
have that that Source available to you
when we don't have rainfall a pine
doesn't have to be huge to be beautiful
and productive more than just a prized
fishing hole a pond serves as a source
of life this is Chuck Denny
reporting